i
[Música]
ah
el 30 de noviembre es el día nacional de
la yerba mate en argentina el mate la
bebida que se prepara con la yerba mate
es la infusión nacional de este país y
es consumido en más del 90% de los
hogares tanto es así que la yerba mate
forma parte de la canasta básica
alimentaria argentina en 2019 los
argentinos consumimos más de 277
millones de kilos de yerba mate y el
país exportó casi 40 millones de kilos a
40 destinos claro en este contexto de
pandemia de kobe 19 hay una parte del
ritual del mate que es compartirlo con
amigos con familiares que no se puede
hacer porque representa un riesgo pero
en este día día del mate aunque sea
solos seguimos tomando
[Música]
estamos en uruguay aquí tomar mate es
ante todo una costumbre personal
los uruguayos vamos por la calle con el
termo y el mate y lo tomamos en todo
momento y en cualquier lugar aunque es
muy común consumirlo en momentos de
descanso en la rambla o en la playa
también lo hacemos incluso en oficinas y
restaurantes cuando lo hacemos en
compañía muchas veces cada persona tiene
su propio mate y su propio termo lo cual
viene muy bien en tiempos de pandemia
por razones climatológicas en uruguay no
se cultiva yerba mate pero es el país
con mayor consumo a nivel mundial
los uruguayos usan 10 kilos de yerba por
persona cada año mayormente de origen
brasileño
el uruguayo utiliza hierbas sin palos y
hace mucho hincapié en esto otra
diferencia es que se utiliza el agua más
caliente que el resto de la
e incluso muchas veces en punto de
ebullición los uruguayos también tenemos
la costumbre de mover la bombilla
y dar vuelta al mate
[Música]
el mate como se llama aquí a la infusión
de yerba mate es una de las bebidas más
populares junto con el café y el té en
siria y en el líbano el consumo del mate
es un reflejo de las fuertes migraciones
de sirios y libaneses a latinoamérica a
principios del siglo pasado que cuando
regresaron a sus países de origen se
trajeron consigo la costumbre de tomar
mate un dato curioso es que los dos
padres del ex presidente carlos menem
son de la ciudad de yabrud donde se
originó el consumo de maten siria
ahora mismo siria es el primer comprador
de mate del mundo y el líbano el año
pasado importó 800 mil kilos de esta
hierba aquí el mate se toma en vasitos
de cristal a falta de calabacita y la
bombilla de metal se fabrica a nivel
local pero es mucho más pequeña
[Música]